I couldn't think what else to do or save
the most Awkward embarrassing moment of
my career in front of the whole lost
cast and crew hi this is Alena Andre and
these are my stunts horror stories
I got casted to play woman at food truck
but it had stunts involved and I had a
couple lines then I was supposed to get
beat up by the lead actress I do my
first take great they loved it and want
to do it again on the second take the
actress was supposed to after I slapped
the fries of her hand she's supposed to
take my head and headbutt me and then he
fall to the ground well what happened
was we were cynical times she
head-butted me but she had bet at her
leg right into my face hit me square the
face square in the nose but that was in
bus part the best part was afterwards in
the scene when the actress wanted to
help me up and as he was helping me up
he stepped on my hair and about this
chunk of hair got pulled out
he saw cuz it happened not as it was big
I felt being ripped out of my head as it
was being pulled I was being pulled up
and you can't I don't want to mess up
the scene so I just rolled with it
obviously this much hair on the ground
and it was this thick and I sat there
and I was like my eyes went big and they
were like cut no yeah the best take care
of her blah blah I was like let me I
need funny cool minutes you know in the
moment when you are doing stunts or any
kind of action acting you know you're
officially getting slim - getting beat
up whatever that was what I expected I
wasn't expecting my hair people I took
two minutes I breathe that came back I
was like okay let's do it again if you
want but man who's been on set for
almost like 20 years that helped me get
the composure I had to not lose my and I
wasn't getting punched the face by the
actor I expected that cuz it's gone
wrong before it was my hair being pulled
out and the next thing I told the extra
mic listen next I could just dip boy
he's like he was he felt so bad and of
course I'm not gonna get mad at him but
next time I help myself out but that's
why they pay stunt actors or action
actors like me stunt performers the big
bucks because when that stuff goes down
you can't get all dramatic and throw a
hissy fit and you like medic and like
whatever even though I got my face
slammed to your thigh
hi I'm Steve Rizzo and this is my stunt
double horror story
I was doubling my actor on a TV show
called life on Mars and I was tackling
another stunt guy off the back of a boat
to the dock below and we take we take a
lot of precautions we rehearse and we
practice and we we knew what we're doing
and it was just one of those fluke
things this particular study I'd never
done before you can rehearse and you can
practice and you can run it a million
times in your head and if something's
gonna happen it's gonna happen if we
went for it and we went over the railing
and our feet got tangled and we didn't
separate and landing flat on our backs
we landed headfirst into the pad and my
neck took the brunt of my weight and his
weight hurts and cracking my life was
flashing before my eyes
I have actually lost a few friends in
the in the 30 years I've been doing this
I didn't know what to expect that was
3,000 miles away from home and thought
I'm gonna end up in a hospital and my
left arm went numb and my left leg went
numb and I was kicking my feet because I
wanted to make sure stuff was working so
I laid there for a good three or four
minutes the stump working it came over
he saw what happened and he was
immediately in my ear and we finally
stood up and I kind of shook it off and
I finished the rest of the fight on the
dock the rest of the day and I went back
to work and ended up having to go to
hospital later that night but also had
me a lot of pain in my neck and running
down my throat and get my arm and into
my leg so they took MRIs and they took
x-rays and everything was intact it was
just stressing of the nerves and the
nerves got angry a few years after that
the top of my left arm and into my
fingertips was still numb that went away
after about two or three years they you
know the thought of it will never go
away and and that's perfectly normal
because I still have a job to do so it
was a scariest time of my life in my
career and that's my son devil horror
story so I was in a wire I had to
backflip into the water but apparently I
didn't know the humic stomach cannot be
upside down more than 20 minutes or 18
minutes and that morning I had a burrito
for breakfast so the scene I just pulled
the red handle and then not to they let
go the water and I just took my body and
did it back
into the river and they had me on wires
because if I would have fallen free fall
would have hit my head and died because
River was like this shallow but it's
like never fails you know I'll have a
seat to do in a in a jerk vest or in a
harness and then they always say it
right after lunch when she want to eat
you know they are trying to positions
the shot and I guess they lost track of
me over there and I was hanging in with
my feet were just like this and I had to
hold myself up with my core and you know
up the tree cuz if I went back down I
would just see you know the river I just
they forgot I was there about 15 18
minutes in I just had a bar and saw them
you saw me barfing the burrito into the
water where I had to go down into and
everyone just stopped and looked at me
like you care record goes kind of went
cracking off and laughing cuz I couldn't
think what else to do or save the most
Awkward embarrassing moment of my career
in front of the whole lost cast and crew
and of course that day that be camera
rolling so it was behind the scenes
camera of that day and of course she's
off on the day I did that I'm sitting
there just like embarrassed but they
thought was the best thing ever
and then like Lena can we need a couple
times like yeah sure let's do it again
and we did it a couple more times wing
backs up into my own dream oh great
Obama in the river so this day I've
never ever bought the lost DVD of that
season cuz I I'm afraid to see what's on
it
one day if I do become famous really oh
you're the girl that threw up in the
river let that one theme like yeah
that's me and I went in it so boom I
like empowering women on film when
powering athletic action women I love
being like a role model for women to
grow and to just embracing their
femininity and their strength that's my
mission in life is to empower and impact
people in a positive way and knowing
everyone is amazing in their own right
and those are my stunt double for my
horse story
[Music]